what do you think what do you think is
the biggest problem we're dealing with
right now in the world oh thank you this
is what I've been spending in the last
20 years of answering it turns out the
question is wrong so the short answer
here is uh the biggest problem in the
world is that we all die
but we don't have you know a good
technology to avoid it so it doesn't
make sense to rank the worst problems
okay it only makes sense to rank what
are the best Solutions so you know you
can't really say what are big problems
because it depends on whether we have
anything to do about it and it turns out
that there are some really really good
solutions to the world's big problem so
you know you mentioned poverty we know
how to get people out of poverty by
getting more trade for instance that is
opening up our trade do you remember you
know 20 years ago everybody was very in
favor of free trade then we started
becoming realizing oh wait there's
actually problems with free trade as
well you know the Rust Belt and that
kind of thing that's absolutely true
we still have not we've kind of lost
sight on the fact that trade still helps
many many more than it inconveniences so
you know for rich countries uh for every
dollar that it cost for people like in
the in the in the Rust Belt It generates
benefits for the US of about seven
dollars so yes we need to compensate
them we need to have that conversation
but for poor countries free trade
generates one dollar problem for every
time it generates ninety five dollars of
net benefits that's incredible this is
you know that's why of course China got
so much richer that's why China Has
Lifted out most of its population now
from poverty this is because of the
power of free trade so that's one of the
many solutions uh do you mind if I give
you a few more go for them good so so
we're actually doing I'm coming out with
a book this month on on what are the 12
smartest things to do so this was one of
the smart things to do education is
obviously a big issue you so education
sucks most places in the world uh it's
certainly uh is terrible for most of the
poor people in the and and the world
they go to school we've managed to do
that and everybody is in school but they
have really really poor education so
they learn almost nothing uh and one of
the reasons is that there is such a big
difference between the best student in
the class and the worst student in the
class if you imagine you put all the 12
year olds together in one grade
obviously some of these kids know
everything the teacher is saying and
more and some of them have no clue
what's going on so the solution to that
is to get more individualized learning
what what they call learning at the
student's own level one way of doing
this is getting kids in front of a
tablet one hour a day
if you do this right the tablet will
have software in the local language that
actually teaches this student and so the
software very quickly figured out oh the
student is really smart so I can Rush
ahead or the student has no clue what's
going on so I'll back up and start doing
this if you do this it'll cost about
thirty dollars per kid per year now
they're not going to get the tablet
they'll share many of them and you know
these poor countries you'll also need to
have solar panels to recharge them at
night and you need a locker to store
them at night so they don't get stolen
that kind of stuff we've calculated all
that and this is done on many many
studies right it'll cost about thirty
dollars per student per year
but it means that each of these kids
over a year will learn what they
normally would have learned on three
years in school they'll simply learn
three times as much now remember it's
still a pretty crappy school so it's
just less crappy now but it means that
they will become much more productive
when they become adults and they will
produce much more it actually turns out
that this benefit delivers about 65
dollars of benefit for every dollar it
costs so again if we do these kinds of
things we could actually make the poorer
part of the world about 600 billion
dollars richer every year by an
investment of about 10 billion dollars
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]